now saturday was a tragic day on turkish
roads at least 32 people died in
multiple traffic accidents in two
separate locations where vehicles
crashed into first responders following
earlier accidents we should warn you
that the following report does contain
footage that some viewers may find
disturbing
a horror day
after multiple crashes on turkish roads
dozens were killed at two separate sites
in the country's southeast
in the gaziantep province emergency
responders and journalists attending the
scene of a crash were themselves struck
and killed by a boss
at about 10 45 in the morning a
passenger bus crashed here
while the fire brigade medical teams and
other emergency workers were responding
to the accident another bus crashed 200
meters behind
this second bus slid into the site and
hit the first responders and the wounded
people on the ground
in a separate accident just a few
hundred kilometers away a truck hurtled
into pedestrians local media reported
that the vehicle's brakes failed
[Music]
emergency workers were already at the
scene
they had been called out to a crash at
the same spot shortly
before
turkey has a poor road safety record and
the victims of friday's accident are a
devastating addition to the thousands of
lives lost each year
you